in December last year I got very excited
for the return of Reckless to fanatic it
was the team that birthed his career and
after a breakup and two years apart they
were finally reunited but fnatic have
just had arguably their worst split ever
and this has turned into a painful
reminder of why you maybe shouldn't call
your ex
[Music]
alright so even though things aren't
going too well for fnatic right now he
is back in the LEC so there's a good
chance we'll be talking about him a few
other times throughout this year if you
like the sound of that then make sure
you are subscribed to the channel and if
you enjoyed this video leave us a like
it really helps which is alright so yeah
last December the big news everyone was
talking about was Reckless returning to
fnatic a lot of League fans will already
know the significance of that but for
those who aren't quite up to speed they
have a lot of history together Reckless
was really there for the beginning of
fnatic's presence in League of Legends
with him as their 80 carry fnatic won
five of the first six splits ever of the
EU LCS together in 2018 they eventually
reached the peak of League itself when
they made it all the way to world's
Grand Final that year it was a big shock
when Reckless joined fnatic's face rival
G2 but despite all of the hype they just
didn't click as a team and failed to
qualify for worlds 2021 then we had all
the drama with G2 benching Reckless
where he later alleged that because of
that he was earning just six percent of
his usual wage on top of that he accused
G2 of setting his buyout figure too high
for other Le seems to acquire him when
he decided to leave with no realistic
LEC options on the table we saw Reckless
head off to the lfl to join Carmen Corp
the tier 2 French team that were
dominating the scene and whose fans fell
in love with Reckless upon his arrival
not only did he thrive on that team and
help him to a European Masters
Championship they also both wanted the
same thing to make it into the LEC
unfortunately it wasn't to be in October
last year coming corp's owner announced
the team had been unable to secure an
LEC spot for 2023 and that brings us to
this season where Reckless rejoined
fnatic for his fifth stint with the org
in the last decade some called it the
Return of the King in the north Reckless
said he regretted ever leaving fnatic in
the first place and there was a sense
among some fans that although this might
not mean an immediate return to the
Glory Days it was where he was supposed
to be home of course there reason I'm
talking to you guys right now is because
so far in 2023 it's not been the fairy
tale homecoming that some people
expected
kick fnatic cannot stand Toe to Toe with
SK gaming and fnatic are eliminated at
the hands of SK with that loss to SK on
Monday fnatic finished the LEC winter
2023 split with a two win seven loss
record leaving them unable to qualify
for the playoffs this isn't just bad
it's historic fnatic have never failed
to qualify for playoffs in 10 years of
playing in the European League no matter
how bad things have got fnatic have
always managed to scrape through and get
playoffs until now not long after that
game Reckless posted a fairly emotional
video to Twitter hello everyone
I wanted to
record something
fresh right after the loss
mostly to
say sorry for
everything
hasn't been
hasn't been a good start to the New Year
Reckless went on to say that far from
contributing to their success so far he
felt like he contributed to their
failure I really wanted to say sorry for
not being able to deliver I haven't
played
I haven't played Goods I don't think I
have been able to contribute much
uh to the team's success in the contrary
I think I have actually
probably contributed more to the team's
failure so it's a
it's a tough moment
for all of us for me to go through for
all of you guys I guess as well to go
through so
I really wanted to
just say something there were times
during that video where I thought
Reckless wanted to go into more details
about how he really felt the split when
and what went wrong but ultimately this
video just felt like a way of
apologizing clearing the air and letting
people know that he does plan on doing a
stream further down the line to share
some more detailed thoughts so what the
hell happened to fnatic then well of
course there are some people out there
that feel the Reckless was at least a
part of the problem in some way some
people point to his small champion pool
as being something that makes a lot of
games for fnatic difficult to play
before the match even begins and this is
something that even former G2 teammate
yankos agreed with on some level
Nicholas doesn't play a lot of Champions
that are like in The Meta but others
such as LS have at times firmly pointed
the finger at reckless's teammates I
wonder like what it takes for Wonder to
have gone from one of the Best Western
top laners to just one of the
worst how could you ever on ironically
requested me out drops in the spot he's
not going to provide any value to the
team his Champion does nothing against
astralis's team composition and the
champion is a detriment to his
own teammates if this isn't mental
Warfare against Reckless if he isn't
trying to send Reckless back to the
URLs I don't know what else this
approx pick is long-time former support
for reckless Hiller sang told m- Esports
that he feels like The Fanatic players
are simply not bonding that they're not
a team and are instead just individual
players trying to solve things on their
own and this is a sentiment Echo by
kadral who feels that fnatic's results
have more to do with what's been
happening out of game as much as they
are playing bad I would attribute their
bad gameplay to something going wrong
behind the scenes personally from my
experience of seeing teams in like four
major regions
over the last like six years
if I had to say what the biggest problem
is something outside of the game just
isn't working like either some of them
don't like each other or
um the mood is just bad and there's no
one to bring it up there's even been
told that the solution is for fnatic to
move the inactive upset back to the
starting 80 carry position and move
Reckless to the support role once again
once again this is the big question once
again that tastes like promotion and I
saw some people pointing out that last
week Reckless played a lot of support in
solo queue so that one might not
actually be too crazy but while everyone
has been discussing who's to blame and
how to fix it something interesting
cropped up Lunette the GM for French lfl
team Aegis suggested on Twitter that
Reckless have been fifth or sixth on the
list of fnatic's preferred ad carries
and that they only went with him because
their first choices didn't want to play
with Rooks their support that they'd
already locked in any roster or staff
shuffling that goes on over the next few
weeks will give a clue as to where
thematic thinks the problem lies fanatic
have apologized as an org and said
they'll be taking time now to reflect on
the winter split and to come back
stronger but a lot of people will be
waiting with anticipation to hear one
person's opinion on all of this Reckless
he's alluded to Breaking everything down
in an upcoming stream and considering
how candid he's been about these sorts
of things in the past I think we might
get some real insight into what's gone
wrong for him and for fnatic
it's just funny looking back at that
video in December where I was like he's
back the king is back it's gonna be
great it's gonna be sick everyone get
excited oh man I think it's just a blip
personally I think that hype video I
made it will stand a test of time I
believe I've Got to Believe